there's more infighting even among
elected officials
right now matt gates who is generally
speaking quite a talented
a congressman matt gates is uh going
after liz chaney liz cheney
is the chairman of the republican caucus
it's
technically a leadership position in the
house but it's not a very important one
liz cheney though voted to impeach
donald trump liz cheney supports the
impeachment of trump very much at odds
with her caucus very much at odds with
her party and matt gates flew to wyoming
to attack liz cheney take a listen i
love
wyoming
i think if liz chaney had a rally with
all of her supporters
they could likely meet inside one of the
elevators in the capitol
and still have plenty of room for social
distancing
[Applause]
i want to thank representative ocean
andrew
his first day as a state representative
was yesterday
and he invited me to be here with all of
you today
i'd say that's a pretty good start for
the young man oh
i'll confess to you this is my first
time in wyoming
i've been here for about an hour and i
feel like i already know the place a lot
better
than your misguided representative liz
chaney
pretty rough attacks now i know that a
lot of people in washington
a lot of washington republicans they say
come on stop it stop the infighting stop
the infighting
and this is this is where conservatives
need to be very
focused we need to be very precise
do we really want to kick out of the
party
liz cheney and people like liz cheney
people who maybe they're more like bush
republicans
maybe they're more like cheney
republicans i don't know maybe they're
more kind of more
foreign policyhawks i don't know more
liberal republicans generally speaking
we want to completely kick them out of
the party i think that would be crazy
you wouldn't wouldn't have enough people
you wouldn't you'd
lose more people than i think those of
us on the conservative side would be
willing to admit
now many people on the liberal side want
to kick out people like matt gates
or they want to kick out people like
josh holy or they want to kick out
people like ted cruz or they want to
who don't even all agree with one
another but they all represent
sort of less liberal elements do we want
to kick those out no we can't do it if
we
do we want a new patriot party that was
another suggestion should there be a new
third party
no if we had a patriot party you just
give all the elections to democrats
however you can't let this kind of
division just fester and fester and
fester
so it would seem to me perfectly
reasonable that liz cheney should not
serve in republican leadership i don't
think she should be kicked out of the
house of representatives i don't think
she should be kicked out of the
republican party
but her position on a very very
important issue
the historic unprecedented second
impeachment of the ex-president
her position on that is
it's too serious it's too it's two at
odds with the party
she cannot make a credible claim to be
leading the party
so she should return to be rank and file
and maybe and and she should still have
her rights to
you know be exercised within the caucus
and within the party
but the conservatives are not going to
effectively
counter the biden administration if we
have leadership
that opposes the conservative base it's
just
not going to happen you know matt gates
talked about in this same speech he
talked about something i'd never heard
about before but it's an interesting
lens through which to view all of this
stuff the opposition to fouchy the robin
hood stuff the infighting on the gop
he called it prairie populism my
grandfather was a small town mayor
in not too distant north dakota he
passed before his time
but not before passing into legend and
he passed along a little wisdom
to my dad my old man calls it
prairie populism do right by your people
never sell out fight their dislikes
and never never let the powerful run
over the week
inspire people through courage
and tell the truth
the truth is that the establishment
in both political parties have teamed up
to screw our fellow americans for
generations
i know that there are many republicans
and conservatives they get
they get shivers when they hear this
word populism
this is happening this
is something that the american people
are sensing
and they are sensing it for good reason
they are sensing that there is something
very corrupt about this establishment
are we really to believe
that the educational establishment is
totally corrupt the administrative state
is totally corrupt hollywood is totally
corrupt
but the big tech totally corrupt
but the financial establishment is like
totally fine 100 totally fine
no foreign policy establishment totally
no
of course not there is something
happening here
senator cruz talks about this as the
republican party becoming the party of
pittsburgh
and the democrats becoming the party of
paris it's a very nice political
formulation of that
for most of my life republicans have
appeared to be the party of plutocrats
now they are the party of the people
some people are not adjusting well to
that
if the republican party is to have an
effective governing coalition
an elected coalition moving forward they
have to be able to make that claim it's
why the left is so
focused on burying these guys who dare
question
the establishment and who dare invoke
the language
of populism if you enjoyed that video be
sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there